[Music]
hello i'm danielle brennan a solution
manager at google and i'm excited to
share with you how you can make
innovation repeatable and scalable and
drive faster outcomes for your business
with google cloud cortex framework
so what is cortex framework well it's
about helping you accelerate innovation
by leveraging best-in-class cloud-native
technologies and solutions
you can think of it as a blueprint to
help you design build and deploy
solutions faster for specific business
needs and it includes out-of-the-box
content to help you reduce the risk
complexity and cost of getting started
we provide reference architectures
solution accelerators and integration
services to help you kick-start your
deployments all built on a foundation of
proven technologies including google
cloud and partner solutions
so what kind of business challenges can
we help you solve for
well google is uniquely positioned to
help you transform your business by
bringing data and software together
by combining the best of enterprise data
like sap and other data sets like google
trends ads and more you can discover and
drive new insights and value for your
business
for example by leveraging technologies
like bigquery for agile data warehousing
at scale and vertex ai for faster
machine learning results with any skill
level you can unlock new insights and
differentiate your business with a
future ready cloud strategy which helps
you better plan predict and perform
to learn more about bigqray and its
value for sap enterprises check out this
video linked in the description below
so how does google cloud cortex
framework help you get started with our
data cloud
well we've introduced a rich set of
business building blocks and templates
for sap enterprises looking to get
started and running quickly
our cortex data foundation for example
provides reference patterns and content
to accelerate data ingestion modeling
and reporting of sap and other data sets
in bigquery and our cortex application
layer provides microservices templates
to securely consume and share results
with downstream systems
this content helps solve for common
lines of business and industry analytics
use cases
let's explore this little further
cortex data foundation provides
pre-defined operational data marts data
processing scripts for things like
change data capture and hierarchy
resolution machine learning samples for
business scenarios like product
recommendations and plug and play
dashboarding templates for common
business scenarios leveraging sap erp
data and other data sets
the best fit is that the content is open
sourced readily available and can be
deployed automagically through
code-based deployment
get started today with the link shown
also get a deeper dive and technical
overview of this content with this video
all links are available in the
description below
cortex application layer also helps
accelerate outcomes for providing
solution patterns for interoperability
between cortex data foundation and other
platforms in a secure and scalable way
this allows you to integrate key
business insights into relevant business
systems and processes where this
information may be useful
all sample code provided is packaged in
kubernetes containers for secure
scalability and is delivered through
google cloud marketplace
you can learn more on the link provided
here or by watching this explainer video
links in the description below
what sort of insights are possible with
the content you might ask
let me start with what this looks like
from a business user's perspective
cortex data foundation provides
predefined data models which enable
various lines of business and industry
use cases some examples are shown here
such as financial and order to cash
analytics as well as more advanced
solutions helping to define and predict
impacts on demand as well as delivery
while we have designed our framework to
be open and you can bring any analytics
reporting tool to it we have also
created dashboarding templates with
looker to help you get started quickly
if looker is your preferred tool of
choice you will find a block containing
pre-defined dashboards leveraging cortex
data foundation models in the liquor
marketplace these reports include
financial insights like accounts
receivables overdue receivables day
sales outstanding and doubtful
receivables and order to cash insights
including sales performance order
fulfillment billing pricing and more
our advanced industry solution templates
combine additional data like trends
weather and more with sap data and apply
machine learning to drive new predictive
insights
take for example our demand sensing
solution
with this template you can kickstart
insights such as identifying potential
impacts to near-term demand plans across
your most important products
for example are there any upcoming
weather events that may impact demand
what about search trends
which could cause sudden higher or lower
demand for a product
or if your marketing team is planning on
an ad to promote a product
what wasn't considered when the demand
plan was originally set
all these insights and more are possible
and while there is some intelligence and
semantics embedded in looker bigquery
and vertex ai are doing the heavy
lifting in data modeling and processing
so you can take these same insights
regardless of your choice of
visualization solution
in summary i hope you are as excited as
i am about google cloud cortex framework
and the amazing content available to
help you get started quickly
google cloud cortex framework helps you
unlock innovation by leveraging
differentiated technology to accelerate
business outcomes with less risk
complexity and cost
if you want to learn more check out
additional videos in this series thanks
for tuning in
you